we have ourselves some royalty
you ready t.j jefferson you wear you
wear a lot of the t-shirts that that
that are combined the essence and name
of this man yes sir
one of the famous most decorated
wrestlers of all time now part of aew
and aew rampage can be seen tonight
at 10 pm eastern on tnt to watch
cm punk take on daniel garcia but before
that cm punk here on the rich eisen show
how are you sir i'm excellent and you
know before we we continue with anything
else when i was uh remodeling my house i
almost put a urinal in it
okay it makes sense now then uh for the
radio terrestrial radio listeners who
were just saying why would cm punk say
that it's just we
we we talked about um meghan trainor and
her husband have uh side-by-side toilets
and you know um i don't got i don't got
anything weird like that but i consider
it a urinal okay and i'll i'll bite uh
why cm
why
um because it was suggested like i would
have what if you put a urinal in here
and i literally just went
i guess that makes sense but uh you know
what no okay skip it that's about how
long it took well i think that's a wise
choice um
[Laughter]
how are you doing man how does it feel
to be back in the game back in the ring
pump it feels great uh it really does
you know it yeah i think um
i missed it without realizing i missed
it you know just the like actually you
know throwing on some boots and some
knee pads and stuff and getting in front
of a live audience
uh
you know there was a point i think where
i had done everything i could possibly
do and there was really kind of no
avenue for me to
enjoy something i used to really really
love and then aew came around kind of um
the spark grew from there the the idea
the possibility that i could come back
and kind of re-engage with my love of
pro wrestling again and that's exactly
where i'm at right now so it feels great
well i interviewed cody and brandy
rhodes together and cody came uh just a
couple weeks ago and cody came on a
couple years ago just when aew was in
its infancy
and uh you know we when i was talking to
the rhodes is the other day because i'm
an nfl network guy now 18 years but but
when we were
just a you know age one year two year
three year we were we were dreaming of
being good enough and legitimate enough
for those in the nfl to want to join us
and then folks like dion joined us and
and then you know uh brian gumbel called
games for us and i think they view your
arrival
um with them as legitimizing their their
infancy now being part and parcel of the
wrestling world how do you feel about
that
uh i i try to keep my feet on the ground
when i hear stuff like that but i i
understand that and i think there's some
truth to it you know i just don't want
it to uh you know blow my ego out the
door you know um
because i do take i do take that as a
quasi responsibility you know like you
know to me like it's great it's great
that i'm here it's great that brian
danielson's here in aw uh but but to me
like we gotta we gotta start the work
you know and and and i don't wanna rest
on my laurels and just be like oh
i'm here now everything's great you know
i wanna do fun stuff but i also wanna
help grow the company so what what did
they
sell you on that you bought what did you
say okay let's do it
why you know it it originally was
nothing that tony con was offering me
you know i i i i
i'm at the point where it's not about
the money otherwise i would have been
back i was gone for seven years i would
have been back at some point you know to
cash grab uh in those seven years
the biggest thing i think the biggest
thing um
you know it was a was a friend of mine
who had left wwe and was signed with aew
and he just started there during the
pandemic
and he unfortunately got a uh a pretty
serious illness
and he passed away like uh
day after christmas last year for this
year actually um
and they did they did a tribute show for
him
and the entire show was dedicated to him
it was very emotional you know pro
wrestling is pretty tight knit community
you know like you cannot see somebody
for 20 years and then you run into them
somewhere and it's just like you saw him
yesterday
uh and i just saw the entire company
come together to celebrate brodie lee
and his family and his
you know two little sons
and that's really resonated with me
because i had never seen anything like
that in pro wrestling before you know
normally it's like a 10 bell salute you
know here's a t-shirt yep we really love
this guy and it's just kind of on to the
next and they just really poured their
heart and soul into
dedicating a show and you know they're
starting a foundation now for him
and that was a big thing that made me go
huh you know all that all that
all that stuff about
pro wrestling being a family backstage
like you know it looks like it's
actually true in this place and then you
know i start watching more shows and i
see more young talent and i begin to see
things that i could be doing within the
parameters of an aew wrestling ring and
i guess i just got the bug again
and then when you returned and you're
standing in a ring and you're in the
united center and the chicago kid cm
punk gets in that ring
and you started talking to the fans it
looked like it got very dusty in there
and i don't mean rhodes looked like it
got really dusty in there with you cm
punk
and i see i was i think i i think i was
i think my eyes were leaking before i
even appeared on camera yeah it was a
really emotional day
it was and you know so now that you are
are back um
and what is your i guess first blush
experience been now that you're after
seven years
what is it exactly that you think you
missed and that you're glad that you
you're no longer missing it
well it's definitely the selfish stuff
like the you know the the roar of the
crowd the adrenaline rush you get um
feeding out the people
uh performing in front of crazy rabid
sold out crowds like 20 000 people at
arthur stadium or you know just walking
out
onto the ramp in front of fifteen
thousand people at the united center
you know those things i haven't done in
so long so it's almost like they're new
again
um engaging
in pro wrestling with
guys who maybe grew up watching me is
kind of a trip but it's exciting too
because there's just this whole new
generation of young hungry wrestlers
that
i guess look up to me as a kind of a
role model and you know so like i i feel
like i'm in this very reggie dunlop slap
shot position of player coach
old gnarly guy who has got a a couple
tricks up his sleeve and you know
wants the team to succeed and win but
you know along the way
helps some guys out
cm punk here on the rich eisen show uh
aw rampage tonight 10 p.m eastern on tnt
you can watch cm punk take on daniel
garcia and and so much more you want to
chime in on the uh naming of justin
fields is the bear's new quarterback cm
punk uh i think it's a little late they
should have done it originally you know
i i think when you draft a guy like
justin fields
in the first round i i think you just
got to go all in you know like you're
never going to be ready
yes you know you know like but if you
wait until you're ready you're you're
never going to wind up playing so just
play the kid let him get some experience
you know build a team up around him i
think we got more problems with the
offensive line than we got with who's
our quarterback no and i know and i
think that's part and parcel of why
maybe some within that organization was
hesitant to throw him out there
my take was he's he's got the pedigree
from his
ohio state party the ohio state um
part of his resume to to withstand
anything and he's got the legs to run
away from the trouble and he's got the
heart and he's got the brains and he's
got the want to
and
when he won his first game
after a first career start wound up in
the ashes of nine sacks it showed he
doesn't get broken
so keeping like what's what gives you
know i agree i agree that we i think
they need to live in the present and he
is the present you put him in there and
you see how he does you can't live in
the you know the future of oh well well
maybe he's gonna get too beat up well
let's see what happens what if he
doesn't you know like i said
if you wait until the guy is ready you
know
you're gonna it's gonna pass you by and
what do you think of the idea that bears
might not play in soldier fields one day
soon but soldier field might be toast
did you hear about that one i i i blame
that on the mayor you know like i i
think that boils down to
you know
the bears not owning the property they
play on
and it winds up being you know they have
to ask the city if they want to do
certain stuff like have you know like
the off-site betting and all that
and you know as an owner i understand
that that's a headache and why wouldn't
you just go buy some property and then
you don't have to ask a landlord
if you can or can't do something with
the place that you basically consider
home so i get it
it's going to be a big change and it's
going to suck but
you know they're 45 minutes to an hour
north depending on traffic i don't think
it's really that big of a deal it's just
an iconic thing you think about when you
hear chicago bears you hear silver
fields so
it'll it'll be an adjustment period but
overall i don't think it should affect
anything cm punk here on the rich eisen
show and watching rizzo uh playing a
playoff game for the yankees schwarber
right now
with the red sox and tonight we're gonna
see chris bryant maybe with the best
chance of one of the former cubs to go
win another one how how does that land
on you
cm punk cubs fan to see these guys all
doing their thing but not for and with
each other
anymore it absolutely absolutely sucks
um
that that team should have been a
dynasty and you know the fact that they
won one
uh
world series is fantastic but when you
when you look at all those pieces and
all those pieces are now scattered all
over major league baseball and playing
on different playoff teams like you know
you got a question like why and
what happened there and what went wrong
um
i'm still kind of hoping some of those
guys
come back to the cubs you know in the
off offseason you know maybe maybe
they're just trying to flee some teams
from for for their prospects and their
picks and stuff but i don't know how
much hope i have in that
um i think the cubs really let the fans
down on that one you know like they they
should have tried to at least keep rizzo
like i get it but i also don't get it it
it's kind of heartbreaking but i i will
root for
chris bryant and i will recalculate a
goal
have you ever done the take me out to
the ball game ceremonial first pitch
double dip in wrigley field cm punk have
you done
yes i have okay how'd that one go for
you
it was a strike it was a heater
uh pardon me for asking but uh i've done
this before dodger stadium and my my
stuff uh would have hit a right-handed
hitter but the left-hander would have
swung over the off-speed junk
um but you were at the top of the
mountain all right you didn't go you you
went to the top and the towed the rubber
right i threw from behind i threw from
behind the rubber what do you mean what
are you talking about no i didn't i'm
kidding yeah
of course i was well you mean some you
know just stand on the flat ground or at
the front of the mound i mean you went
to the intimidating a lot a lot of my
friends who wind up doing it they call
me and they ask me and they go what's it
like and i say it's it's literally
intimidating it's you walk out there and
you don't realize how many people are
there and you don't realize how high
that mound is and how far away home
plate is
it's a stressful situation and then to
take me out to the ball game you know
you think that uh you know you're
supposed to sing it fast but the
organist goes very slow that's when you
wind up sounding like ditka you know
what i mean so you got to let that you
got to let the crowd just sing it okay
kind of just let them take it that's so
cool
you must have loved that that must have
been like a day in your life right there
man
yeah yeah absolutely yeah i mean
definitely a top five highlight of uh
you know
chicago phil's uh life for sure last one
for you cm punk i'm gonna hand things
over to my die hard wrestling fan and a
die hard fan of yours uh right here on
the rich eisen show our social media
grand maester tj jefferson who may have
to pull an audible because i think your
first question tj is why didn't you
build a urinal in your house right yeah
i mean it's answered that that's now
been asked and answered yeah okay so now
so you have to go you know with another
question another question go for it i'll
give you the floor here well punk rich
has been saying how excited i am that
you're calling onto the show and i mean
i guess you could say i'm excited i mean
my fantasy football team has been called
best in the world for eight seasons and
if you go to my crib my wi-fi is best in
the world and my iphone wake-up song
when i wake up in the morning is called
a personality so i guess you could say i
i dig cm punk just a little bit but uh
you know the question i want to have is
you know we don't want to look to the
past we already know what happened back
then let's look to the future and this
forbidden door that's going on in
wrestling right now man like
is there any chance that we'll see you
in addition to aew kind of
hit up new japan so we can see some
matches with okada and tana hoshi and
naito or is that something you're not
looking forward to or not looking at
right now are you just looking to like
really help grow aew
i'm for sure you know
both feet in on on aew but i you know i
know a lot of the new japan guys wind up
coming over and wrestling on adw
dynamite rampage and
um
i'm not adverse to the idea you know uh
but i know they're in the throes of
their g1 tournament and stuff like that
so i don't know
if they can spare the guys and i think
because of the pandemic you still don't
see a whole lot of you know travel from
you know
america to japan
i definitely think you'd have to do a
hard two-week quarantine
once you got to japan and i just don't
think
that's a that's a viable option at this
point you know like
uh i gotta do that when i take acting
gigs and that's hard enough you know so
then to to be in japan for two weeks to
sit in a hotel i'd probably lose my mind
but yeah i i'm for sure i'm for sure
interested i mean you said you said
okada and i think
i think that's a guy i'd definitely be
interested in getting in the ring with
because again you know gone for seven
years the rise of everybody who
has become a superstar in in my absence
like i definitely want to get back in
the ring with and he's he's probably the
number one guy over there
no doubt okay thank you cm punk really
appreciate this we'd love to do this on
the regular as much as you'd like we'd
love to just have you
you guys you guys let me know we can
talk chicago sports we could talk yeah
we could talk everything but we we won't
talk about urinals anymore i promise
well i mean again that's asked and
answered you know i was gonna say that
if you do go over to japan you can
definitely they've got the seat warming
toilets there and i'm assuming that's
what meghan trainor and her husband have
next to each other one of those things
but let's get into some comments
i got one of those i got one of those
ladies and gentlemen cm confirmed
let's tweet that out tweet that out
tweet that out uh thanks for the call
enjoy tonight and let's do this again
really appreciate it absolutely
appreciate you guys thanks a lot right
back at you at cm punk on twitter and
instagram aew rampage tonight 10 eastern
on tnt
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here